negative thoughts aren't the problem
believing them is and sometimes we have
to be our biggest fan
and we have to feed ourselves with the
things that we need to hear to continue
going what is that phrase that you need
to hear when you need it most
think of it from what would you want
your mentor to tell you what would you
want your best friend to tell you and
then
make sure that you become your own
mentor and your own best friend
in those moments when it matters most
what's it like working with the new york
yankees
um well so i don't know i don't know if
you knew this
um i actually broke off from the yankees
in
february i did not what are you doing
now yeah so i have my own consulting
company now
that i do uh i work with all sorts of
athletes and companies and executives
and ceos
um but i would love to tell you about my
time there
because it was very formative those
four years i was with the inky's was
extremely formative into
the position that i am in now and
working with the yankees is pretty
incredible for a lot of reasons but one
of the biggest reasons is the standards
that they hold
themselves to and
they hold themselves to an extremely
high standard and not in the way that's
unrealistic but in the way that if you
think you can do this we think you can
go further
and if you essentially success to the
yankees is if you win a world series
so a couple years ago when we got close
you know they were people were like what
a great season
and if you would say that to anyone in
our organization they would have told
you
no it was a crap season a good season is
winning the world series
so i think that because you're
surrounded by the that level of
expectation
and by such brilliant minds
in baseball and in all these other areas
and realms that
and resources we pull from that um
because you're in that environment you
have no other choice but to level up
yourself
how common is that degree of excellence
chasing
in baseball at large
i would say it's pretty common in terms
of
you know levels of excellence and i
can't speak for really many any other
clubs because i've
not worked with them but i can say that
the level of expectation
feels different at the yankees and i'll
tell you why
because of the name there's a lot that
comes with it
and so you have a lot of eyeballs on you
and like
come on if you either love or you hate
the yankees there's really no in between
and so because of that including your
own fans
some days they love you when you're
performing well and when you're not
they hate you so it's learning not to
ride the roller coaster
of the outside noise and being able
to define what excellence means not only
towards the mission but also for your
own kind of
internal scoreboard i imagine that
produces some
very unique challenges as a mindset and
mental toughness expert
very yeah very lots of challenges
especially especially deriving from
constantly needing to perform uh
that it's not easy especially with as
long of a season as baseball is
what about baseball as a sport obviously
i'm from the uk but there'll be
a lot of american people listening to
whom they're going to cringe at my lack
of knowledge about it
what would you say is some of the the
unique challenges that baseball as a
game
presents there's a lot of pausing
and so like for instance uh soccer
i played soccer growing up my whole life
um it's constant
right it's you know yeah you lose the
ball you get on defense
you win the ball you're on attack like
you're it's non-stop
in baseball there's a lot more downtime
in between
really similar to golf where you
strike out or you don't locate your
pitch or
you know in golf you you just completely
screw up your tee shot and you land in
the water
you now have time between your next
shot between your next opportunity
and those we have to maximize the
opportunities we have
and so a lot of times the pressure can
increase and it can rise especially for
you know give an example of a player
that's in a slump
you know he's over and he is he needs to
get a hit
and so every every time he's at the
plate
just the pressure of having to perform
increases
tremendously and so being able to manage
the pressure
that is required especially when you're
not performing well
can be difficult and it's really
managing those in-between moments
so that we can maximize the time we do
have that's cool the fact that it's
discreet and iterative as a game that
you
you progress through it step by step by
step as opposed to this continuous flow
that you get in other sports
i imagine there must be some players
who are unbelievably talented athletes
and probably could have tried their hand
at a number of different sports
and made it through into baseball but
found that their mentality
was built to be that of someone playing
a continuous game
or perhaps somebody that played football
but has the mentality of somebody that
would have preferred to have played an
iterative game
like cricket or golf or whatever um
and i guess you never really know you
don't ever get to split test your own
life so you can't go back to being
10 years old and decide to pick up a
golf club instead of picking up a pair
of football boots right
um given the fact that you've worked
with some of the most elite athletes in
the uh nlb
mlb yep yep yep got it um what are the
differences between
the good ones and the elite ones
that's a great question because there's
a couple things
but if i had to sum it up i would say
the elite ones are willing to do the
things that the average ones aren't
they are willing to
pay that extra attention to detail
they're willing to remain disciplined
when their circumstances
aren't they're willing to
bounce back from adversity and they're
able to bounce back from adversity
faster
because they're willing to look at what
you can gain
from it and i think one of the biggest
predictors of success
especially in a game like baseball
is the ability to see the opportunity in
the struggle
because it's a game full of struggles
it's a game full of ups and downs it's a
game full of failures and
if you're able to see the opportunity
and that
the ability to bounce back is much
quicker and i think
i always explain it like if you think of
just like a
high and low right you even draw it out
and you draw kind of like a really high
peak and then a really low peak
that is really consistent with maybe
somebody that's a little bit more novice
in baseball or maybe they haven't made
it to the major league level
and then you go to a very elite level
it's not that those highs and lows have
been eliminated
that's not going to be eliminated you're
going to have highs you're going to have
lows no matter what level you're at
it's just the in between shrinks so
instead of this really high peak
we have a peak but then it it goes down
and it goes up and it goes down much
faster
than the average and so i think that has
to do that in between
has to do a lot with your ability to
manage uh
and build a relationship with discomfort
that is interesting yet i think james
clear in atomic habits he interviewed
someone
is it the head of the chinese
weightlifting team and he says what's
the difference between
the best in the world and everybody else
and
the coach said it's the one that can
deal with the boredom of daily training
the best
they just turn up and they grind and
matt fraser crossfit games champion five
times over he talks about this he says
people think
that he's pumped every time to go in
he's like if i'm doing a mono-structural
workout if i've got 45 minutes of
threshold rowing intervals
no one's excited for that nobody the
keenest rower in the history
isn't excited to do that but i do it
and breaking the
veneer that people believe around great
athletes
that well yeah it's easy for him because
he's pumped to go into he's like i'm not
i just
do it and this is what david goggins
says as well right that he
detests public speaking but he goes and
does public speaking
he detests learning stuff so he goes and
learns even more he
is crap at running and he's fat and he's
all the rest of these things
so that is i'm going to guess finding
the opportunity in the challenge
yes and that's doing the things most
aren't willing to
most people especially at that level
like
if you take our like an entire minor
league system our entire system of any
club
you're going to be able to split them up
into some categories and one of the
categories are going to be the people
that are willing to do the things
that are boring they're they've
they're willing to do the things that
are monotonous in nature
that aren't exciting but those are the
small details that add up to big ones
and
i love james clear and in his book i
love this example when he talks about
this
is that if a plane takes off in la and
its destination is new york city
if it just adjusts the nose three
degrees south
it when it's when it's multiplied across
the united states
they're gonna land in washington dc and
so those little things that we do on a
daily basis
while three degrees doesn't seem like
much it starts off looking like three
feet
when we do it every single day it and
then we maximize or we
multiply it across a season
you end up in a whole different place
than somebody else
and confucius said the man who moves
mountains
starts by moving away small stones and
so that's
what we're talking about is they're
willing to move away that small stone
every day when most people look at the
small stone and say that's not gonna
make a difference
i was gonna say is that why you think
the not
elite athletes don't do it is it because
they don't believe that the small
victory victories the one percent do add
up or is there something else in there
so i think there's a couple things at
play one of them is they don't see the
benefit because they're so
locked in on the big details and this is
what i have to say about details is that
the big details are the obvious ones
but the small details are the important
ones
because while the big details they're
obvious because there's an immediate
there's an immediate consequence what
like
so if if a big detail so you want to
make sure that you're
pitching well in a game it's the world
series
those details are easy to to pay
attention to because they're big
and if you don't pay attention to them
it's an immediate consequence you know
if my picture is going into the world
series and
he doesn't do his homework on the on the
batters he's gonna face
that can have a negative impact and it's
pretty immediate
where if he does if he
doesn't do that in game one of this of a
hundred and you know
seventy plus game season they're like
it doesn't totally matter because you
know even even though we think it
matters
they don't see it because it doesn't
matt that game doesn't mean as much the
consequence isn't as high
and so with the problem with the small
details is that by the time
you realize that it's important
it's often too late because
it is this lagging measure
because it it keeps up with you later
i'm sure
i keep quoting james clear but it's
because his book is phenomenal and he he
illustrates this so well is that we are
a lagging measure of our habits
and so you know your finances are a
lagging measure of your spending habits
your weight is a lagging measure of your
eating habits and so forth
and so when we think of these small
details you know working out once
is not you're not gonna leave the gym
suddenly in shape but if you
work out consistently over you know
three months time
eventually you're gonna walk out and go
wow you're gonna look different you're
gonna feel different
your endurance is going to look
different and so i think that's where
those small details we want an immediate
result
but small details require trusting the
process
even when the result isn't there i've
been saying about consistency a lot as
well recently that
more people are talented or enthusiastic
than are consistent
so there's a ton of people who find new
enthusiasm for a project they decide
that they're going to start
a youtube channel or a podcast or maybe
begin playing a sport so they're all
motivated to begin
and then maybe some other subset or
maybe even a subset of those people
will find out oh wow i'm actually fairly
talented at this so i can
have a conversation and it goes well i
really enjoy being on camera or
i've got good endurance so when i go and
play football or whatever i
have a natural talent for it there are
more people out there who are
enthusiastic or talented than consistent
because everybody encounters the
challenge
ninety percent of podcasts don't make it
past episode three
and of the ten percent that do 90 don't
make it past episode 20.
so simply by making it to episode 21
you're in the top percentile
simply by getting to episode 21 you're
in the top percent now are you going to
be in the top percentile for talent or
enthusiasm
no do you even control those things no
but do you get to choose whether or not
you turn up every day
of course you do that is the thing which
is entirely within your power
so i advise people i was like look if
you're praying for something don't pray
for talent or enthusiasm pray for the
strength to keep going
because that will select you out from
your competition
far more quickly than anything else will
so well said it's it's so well said and
it it's true
i literally said this to my husband this
morning that we were on the same
wavelength golfer right
yeah professional golfer working his way
up um
and i said this morning i said half of
success
is showing up long enough to see it
it's being it's sticking with it long
enough
to where you can see the fruition you
can see the fruits of your labor
come to life and there's most people
are not not most yeah most people won't
stick out that long
you'll you'll beat half the competition
by just continuing to show up
and you know i think one of the things
that we can do because i mean
the cool thing is that goals are awesome
like big fan obviously like big believer
in setting goals
um big believer in going through like
you know
what we need to do to create those goals
and get there big believer in developing
your why
there's one aspect that gets overlooked
which is one of the most important
aspects of goal setting
which is instead of just focusing on
what you want to have happen which is
the fun part
and we all love to do is focusing on
what you're going to do when things go
wrong
when you start thinking about what
obstacles would stop you
limit you from continuing on your
journey
and so in psychology we call this mental
contrasting and so
you'll start out and you'll visualize
what you want to have happen you know
connect to those feelings of
accomplishment
you know not not worrying about the how
just the what like what do you want it
to look like
well you know what kind of car are you
driving like what what home are you in
really kind of
coming up with that that image and then
the other side of that
is what could get in the way of you
making progress to that goal
what are some things that might stop you
and when we start to consider those
things i will tell you that
it starts separating the people that are
interested
and the people that are committed
because those that are committed
are going to look at that and then the
second half of that is creating some
contingency plan around
it all right if this happens then
this is what i'm going to do instead or
this is how i'm going to respond to it
if this happens
this is how it's going to happen and so
with a lot of my clients especially are
dealing with
issues with consistency towards a goal
is what
can take you off the tracks what has and
you can you can
think about past mistakes what has taken
you off before
you know for a lot of people that want
to get healthy okay what has stopped you
before
from continuing that journey and then
let's work through what we're going to
do if and when that does happen
because what we do is we're creating a
connection in our brain
between a situation we may face
and then an action or a behavior we want
to follow
and our brain loves us and so if you're
in a situation where
you have a goal and you're going after
it and you want to develop consistency
don't just think about what you want to
have happen also think about what would
get in the way
of it happening and how you'll deal with
it and how you're going to deal with it
i love that i've been thinking a lot
recently about think like an athlete
it's the title of a blog post that i
think david perrell wrote a couple of
years ago i haven't got it out of my
head
and you are someone who's worked with
elite athletes so you are my sounding
board for this
little mental model that i've come up
with um
what i've come to believe is that
almost no other industry in the world
apart from athletes athletics
almost no others take
their preparation for their chosen
pursuit
as wholesale as globally as athletes do
so
with an athlete their nutrition styled
in their sleep styled in
the way that they spend their time
socially the bonding that they have with
the team they're watching game tape of
what's coming up
they're doing their conditioning they're
doing their stretching they're doing
skill drills
they're doing their endurance they're
recovering right they're foam rolling
they're hydrating everything that they
do their entire life is
permeated it's infused with this
desire to facilitate the best
performance that they can have when they
step out under the field
and i don't think that there's any other
industry that does this
maybe chess champions and stuff like
that i'm not sure how far they're
pushing their performance
but even if you think about the absolute
best of the best of the best
on the public speaking circuit or
in the youtube world right the degrees
of freedom
that you have for people not knowing
where your performance is at comparative
to previous performances and also
comparative to your competitors
are so murky
in the way that they're measured there
isn't if there's a 300 kilo bar on the
floor and you need to pick it up
we know if you've picked it up or not
you know if you've picked it up or not
you know what you can pick up and
how close it was to what you were doing
during the on-ramp building up towards
peaking ready for the meat and so on and
so forth
but you don't have that equivalent in
almost anything else there's no
objective metrics
there's no tight parameters for success
and failure you don't know
what what has contributed to the
performance that's come out of you
and what i've been thinking a lot
recently is we're talking about
commitment
right but there's only a very small
subset of people who want to make that
one thing that they want to become
perhaps one of the best in the world or
the best in their country or the best in
their region at
is athletics only a small subset of
people are actually doing it
within a sporting pursuit right so how
can we take the principles
that athletes use to maximize their
performance
and how can we apply them to all of the
things that we don't believe
that is applicable to because i've tried
to do it since i was thinking about it i
turned pro
last year with the podcast and that
meant that
i started to read things that i knew
that would facilitate me i focused on my
sleep because i knew if i'm better slept
then i can talk with more clarity i got
a speech coach and i got a theater and
acting coach so that
i would have more vocal dynamic range
and my diction would be more precise and
i thought okay well if i want to do this
i need to train because if i train well
then my mind's moving quickly
and i'm i'm not even close to like a
sunday league footballer
in terms of the level of preparation
that i do for the thing that i have
classed as my calling
so first of all your thoughts around
think like an athlete in kind of this
sort of
cognitive athlete worlds that i'm
talking about here and then
let's go through some of the things that
people can do they want to become better
at what it is that there is
is their chosen pursuit and let's run
through some some of those
strategies yeah um
when i'm speaking with corporate clients
a lot of them come to me because of my
work with the yankees
and one of the first parallels i draw
is what makes an elite major league
baseball player
mentally is the same thing
that makes an elite executive an elite
ceo an elite parent
an elite significant other an elite
friend
there are so many parallels the thing
that changes
is the language so instead of talking
baseball you know i'm talking ceo
and so the language changes but many of
the principles
are very similar if not the same cool
what are
what is what are some of the biggest
ones of that
well one of the ones that you kept
talking the word that kept coming to my
mind as
you were saying what you were saying is
purpose
that what athletes have done is
everything that they do
has a purpose
and i'm gonna quote my good friend
justin sue here when he says
do things on purpose with purpose
and so one of the things that every so
every elite individual that i've worked
with
has is a routine that starts their day
and there's you know the principle that
things in motion
tend to stay in motion and so how are
you getting in motion in the morning and
maybe your day doesn't start in the
morning maybe it starts at night you
know everybody's
uh schedules are different but how you
start your day
sets the tone for the rest of it and so
i know that when i don't do my routine i
feel like i have like 10
to 15 tabs open and they're not in order
and then i'm having to use the rest of
my day to organize them
where now when i i have an evening
routine that actually sets up my morning
routine
and i decide what my morning routine is
going to look like at the end of the day
and so one of the ways that we can do
this
because a lot of times we wake up in the
morning and then we decide what we're
gonna do
and so one of the ways we can do this is
the night before
you know i i have two categories i have
a category of scheduled so these are you
know
appointments uh with clients this is
doctor's appointments this is all the
things that i've scheduled for that day
and then i have my high important tasks
and these are the tasks that i like
these are the things that i want to get
done that day and i list them in order
of priority
and then i then i write a time stamp
next to them
and so i can organize my day based on
those two things
the next morning i know exactly where
i'm supposed to be at 6 30 a.m
i know exactly where i'm supposed to be
at eight o'clock
i know exactly where what task i'm
supposed to be working on at 2 p.m
and so what it does is it takes the
guessing out of it the same way we plan
our contingency plans with our brain and
say oh
if this happens then i'm going to do
this we are scheduling and creating a
plan that our brain
no longer has to decide it simply has to
execute
and what we know is that we only have so
many dis we have decision making power
and it depletes throughout the day the
more decisions we make and so again
okay if we do this at the very end of
our day the night before
we wake up and we have already made 90
of the day's decisions in terms of what
we're going to be working on
and we can spend the rest of that energy
working on those things and making
decisions within them
and so that's one thing that we can all
do is adopting an evening and a morning
routine
splitting off planning and execution is
a
it's such a hack it's such an easy hack
and let's draw it back across to a
sports analogy
the players might try and change the
plays
during the game but the actual
fundamental way that they do the plays
isn't they're not coming up with new
pitches on the fly
he's i've practiced this one a million
times before i've thrown this a million
times
and the catch has caught it a million
times and we know where the field is and
we know i don't know anything about
baseball
um can i am i pulling it off that i
might know something about yeah you're
doing good you're doing fantastic person
um yeah they they separate out planning
and execution
i had stephen kotler on the show from
the flow research
collective a couple of months ago and he
has this saying and
god it absolutely nailed me he says
um one of his friends was very
disciplined
and he asked him how is it that you're
able to continue doing these hard things
every day
and he said i don't know what you're
talking about man i'm just working for
the boss
and what he meant was when he writes
down the things that he's supposed to do
the night before
he's in manager mode and then when he
goes and does them the next day
he's in employee mode and he just
referred to himself
he was like no i don't know what you're
talking about man i just i just worked
for the boss the boss wrote it down and
i've i've got to do it's on the piece of
paper you know so tell me to do this i'm
just working for the boss
i love it i love that analogy but you're
right
you know in in baseball you know our
guys are not coming up with new routines
at the plate every time
that's what i meant to say that's that's
that's what i was yeah yeah no it was
good it was good i i caught your joke
very well well um you know our
infielders they're
they're not developing you know new in
between
you know in between pitch you know
resets for them
they have it's already ready to go and
you're right there's the difference
between planning and execution
and i'll tell you right now if you have
it planned and you're under a high level
of stress
your execution your ability to execute
is going to go down
you may get lucky every once in a while
you may be okay every once in a while
but if you're not
preparing and planning in a way that
allows you to freely execute
without a high degree of thinking when
the pressure is on
you're going to struggle i love that
what about self-talk how can we improve
our self-talk like an athlete
oh this is a huge one huge one um
because the way you
describe yourself to you
impacts not only the way that you see
yourself
but the way that you perform in big
moments
and so a lot of i actually um i had a
player who
was really really struggling with this
and he would consistently
beat himself up after every mistake that
happened
and there was one time when he was he
got sent down
from triple a to double a and i or i'm
sorry double a to single and i was at
single a and he
walks into my office slams the door
behind him and just like starts venting
and i was like oh well hello i wasn't
expecting to see you here but he had
just arrived
and he's like he's like yeah i didn't
expect to see me here either
he's like this is bs and he just starts
kind of going in like i don't believe i
should have been sent down
i'm better than so so and so and i
should be up there
and then hit self-doubt it's like he
started venting
and then self-doubt started to creep in
and he's like if i can't even execute at
that level
like what makes you think that i can do
it at a major league level
and so he starts you know going into
this kind of like pretty negative
self-talk
and so i stopped him and i said okay i
was like i understand
how frustrating this situation is and i
said i want you to think about this for
a second
let's pretend you're you've made it to
the major leagues it's game seven of the
world series the most important game
of the entire year and you're asked to
come into pitch you're asked to close
and your catcher goes down
your manager gives you an offer an
option you can either
choose a guy behind the plate that has
never failed that has pretty much like
went through the system very quickly and
made it up to the top
or would you want the person that has
failed many times to get to where he is
now
to the major leagues which one would you
want behind the plate
in the world series he's like oh like
the guy that failed
and i said why he goes well because he
knows how to handle failure in big
situations
the guy that's never failed i don't know
how he's going to respond especially in
the biggest moment
of the year and so of course that's what
i
wanted to hear so i was really proud of
this answer
and i turned it back to him and so i
said you have an opportunity right now
to respond and build your response to
failure
what you're going through sucks i'm not
trying to take away that feeling from
you that's that's
that's real but i said you have an
opportunity
to respond differently and so we
went through this exercise of
controlling what we can control
and i asked him i was like you need to
own your three feet
around you anything within your
three-foot world
you have to totally own when you're out
there so i was like what are those
things
we completely went over those things and
then we talked about
all right what is the thing that you
need to hear
when things aren't going well and we
addressed
what that was and essentially he goes
out
he ends up closing a game and he strikes
out three out of the four
hitters that he faced and they won the
game and
he came back to me and i was like how'd
you do
he's like i just owned my three-foot
world and i let the rest take care of
itself
and so for him reminding himself in
those
times the first batter he faced he
or he they got a hit and so imagine
feeling the way you're feeling the first
one in
that's when you feel it i'm like it's
your response it's your response and
when he was able
he was i was able to feed myself with
what i needed to hear and john gordon
talks about this and one of the things
i'll say
is that he says he talks about this uh
dr james gills and he was a
try i think extreme triathlete i'm gonna
get this i always watch this story i
should really
work on this story myself uh but
essentially he runs like a
an extreme triathlon and then like 48
hours runs another one and he was the
oldest person to do this it was like in
his late 50s
and he asked him he said how do you do
it and he goes i i learned
to talk to myself instead of listen to
myself
because when i talk to myself i can feed
myself all the things that i need to
hear to keep going and when i listen to
myself i listen to all
i hear all the negative i hear all the
things that the reasons why i can't and
the reasons why
i'm limited and so for both dr james
gills and my player
elite individuals no matter what sport
or
not or non-sport you're in
negative thoughts aren't the problem
believing them is and sometimes we have
to be our biggest fan
and we have to feed ourselves with the
things that we need to hear to continue
going
and so i don't know what that is for you
or for anybody listening to this but
what is that phrase that you need to
hear when you need it most
think of it from who would you what
would you want your mentor to tell you
what would you want your best friend to
tell you and then make sure that you
become
your own mentor and your own best friend
in those moments when it matters most
that's awesome that's so good i love the
third party perspective as well stepping
back and trying to develop that
metacognizance a little bit
okay where am i what's happening we've
planned for this this is what's
this is why i'm here this is one of the
reasons i'm here this is a feature it's
not a bug
i'm playing baseball the point of the
baseball is for the batter to hit the
ball it's going to happen
inevitably how do we respond i suppose
as well
coming at it from the james clear habit
setting example
the more that you drill poor responses
to failure the more likely that response
to failure is to occur again
so breaking that cycle gets even more
important
oh yeah huge and that's one of the one
of the biggest things that we teach
is you know i think mental toughness
often times is accepting our reality and
choosing our response
there's a lot of things that happen that
i mean when things are good
mental toughness is easy we're like yeah
i got motivation
yeah i want to show up oh success is fun
but it's oftentimes when things aren't
going well
and so it's often our response to those
things because they're inevitable and
when people say oh well can i
how do i eliminate distraction well
there's only a certain amount you can
eliminate and the others
we're going to have to learn a response
when we become distracted
and we can try and eliminate failure to
our best ability but there's going to be
some failure so how do we increase
improve our relationship with it so that
we can improve our response
so i think that a lot of it has to do
with that and what you're saying is
choosing
that better response and that better
habitual setting
so that when that happens our bounce
back becomes quicker
what about pain and discomfort how do
athletes deal with that it's probably
fairly common i'm going to imagine and
baseball looks like a pretty brutal
sport for
rotator cuffs and knees and faces
sometimes
yeah we actually had this is actually a
pretty funny story but kind of lends
back to that
uh perspective piece we had this uh it
was one of my first years with the
yankees this player is
really really good like really talented
and loved the game
the poor guy just always got injured and
not like little injuries like
just didn't have good luck and he had
just gotten back from his
horrible ankle injury and he's at the
plate
and he takes one off the shin like a 90
mile an hour fastball like
right off the lower shin and i had just
finished showing him this video
um from jocko willink uh
who i just love and it was called good
good and he talks about
yeah so i just finished showing him this
video
about like you know changing our
perspective and reframing the things
that like you know if you don't make the
team all right more time to train
if you don't get the plane time you
think okay more time to
to earn it and so he gets hit and he
turns around and looks at me and he just
goes
good and we all just
lost it we were laughing so hard we were
just like oh my gosh
poor guy oh it broke our hearts at the
same time but
uh i think that there's a part of it
you know when it comes to pain and when
it comes to injuries
um the first thing that has to shift
is kind of is our goals
our goals change a little bit so our
goals become more therapy focused our
goals become
you know more daily focused and so we
shift there so that we can have kind of
we can create that light at the end of
the tunnel especially when it feels like
that light just got shut off
with an injury so we start to create
those moments where these little
milestones where we can work towards
because that's one of the things like an
athlete without a goal
is is lost so we try and recreate that
to define success
that's more within their control not
success obviously out in the field or
stat wise because that's been taken away
um when it comes to discomfort
i think a lot of people in my field feel
this way but
our brain is wired for comfort
it's wired to try and keep us safe
but the problem is that as we have
evolved and or the human race has
evolved
one of the things that hasn't is that
protective mechanism in our brain
and sometimes it jumps in to protect us
when we don't need protecting and that's
when it tells us like this is scary
maybe you shouldn't try it you know
you there's no guarantee of success like
why do it
oh you failed ah that's all right at
least you tried we're done
there's all these different things that
kind of come into play in terms of
protection and now a lot of that looks
like
instead of looking like life or death
like it was originally designed for
now we're looking at it like uh threats
socially
threats in our job and so one of the
things that we talk about
is that discomfort isn't always bad and
comfort isn't always good
comfort can lead to complacency and
discomfort is the only way that we can
improve in terms of growth
and so i like to call discomfort is kind
of like
the um the growth zone when we're in it
and there's a
study done by european dodson uh harvard
psychologist where it was called the
the optimal zone of anxiety and it was
kind of this u-shaped bell curve and
right when we are when we're on the left
side of the bell curve that's the
comfort zone right
we got the maps memorized we know which
streets to turn down which ones not to
and then when we get towards the top
that is the optimal zone for learning
because we are just slightly outside of
our comfort zone
we are just slightly we have our toes
just like right on the line
of our current ability and that is where
growth happens now it doesn't mean
go all the way on the other side because
then that leads to panic and that leads
to you know some
setting ourselves up for failure but
it's just right outside of that comfort
zone and so
the way that we grow is by existing
there
and studies show that we don't need to
exist there all the time but if we exist
there you know
about you know 20 20 to 30 of the time
that's where growth happens right there
and so for our guys we're constantly
trying to put them in positions of
discomfort
both mentally and physically
and so it's not always you know pushing
them to the edge
in terms of weight training even though
there's certainly a place for that
sometimes it's working on you know
meditation
and or working on focus or working on
you know being consistent
and in those ways we're challenging our
ability to do that because there's so
many things that are getting in the way
and so when we do this
we develop a relationship with
discomfort and instead of
running from it we rewire our brain to
lean into it
because we know that what we want's on
the other side of it
leaning into discomfort as if you
invited it through the door is a term
from ben bergeron's chasing excellence
and he's coached crossfit games
champions and stuff i absolutely love
thinking about that
that the discomfort really is a feature
not a bug this is why you're here that's
the little mantra that
my my favorite mantra for going through
discomfort
is this is why you're here you're here
for the discomfort you weren't here for
the warm-up
you weren't here for set one or set two
or set three you're here for set four
five and six
that's why you're in the gym that's why
you're doing the
podcast that's why you are here for the
conversation
which pushes the limits of your
cognitive ability
that where you're forced to bring
everything you're getting examples from
when you were nine years old in a
desperate attempt to try and make this
conversation work
that's why you're here and when it comes
to reframing sam harris has this example
where he talks about
imagine the level of fear that you would
be in
if you just spontaneously felt
like you did at the end of a workout
whilst sat in your car
you would [ __ ] yourself you would think
what
the actual [ __ ] is happening to me
i'm sweating i'm so hot i'm out of
breath i feel
anxious okay and yet that's
the outcome that people chase in the gym
around the world
every single day so what does that tell
us it tells us
that the effect the outcome the
sensation that we have
doesn't actually matter anywhere near as
much as our interpretation of what that
means
it's so true and it reminds me of this
analogy
of a butterfly i heard this from a
friend of mine and
this guy's sitting on his porch and he
sees a butterfly in a cocoon
and he sees it trying to you know get
out of the cocoon
and it's it's about halfway open and
it's struggling
and he's like wow what a cool
opportunity to watch this so he's
sitting there and he's watching it
and the butterfly just stops
and he's like he feel like almost like
it gave up and
he felt so bad that he ran inside and he
grabbed the the scissors
and he snipped it open and the butterfly
fell out
and he was so excited to like watch it
you know fly away and grow
and see the beautiful wings but he goes
i noticed something that was different
the body was really swollen and the
wings were all shriveled up
and he's like oh that's all right you
know i'm sure it has all his growth you
know things to do and
so he's like watching it and the outcome
was is that this butterfly
never grew and what he didn't realize
was it was the struggle getting out of
the cocoon
that actually forced that fluid from its
body into its wings
to fully develop and so it's often times
our struggles that form our strengths
it's these moments of discomfort it's
the moments of struggle it's the moments
when you feel like giving
up and maybe quitting is your best
option
those are the moments that form our
greatest strengths and
tony gonzalez hall of famer said this he
goes i was
i was leading the league and dropped
passes
and he says dropping the football is
actually the thing that taught me to
catch it
he said i'm so thankful for that now
because that's exactly what made me the
player that i am today
or i was then i guess he's retired now
but
what about not being outcome focused
especially
in sport the scoreboard at the end of
the day
is the thing which matters most and a
lot of the time we have externalized
quantified objective metrics of success
followers revenue growth year on year
sales
whatever it might be my kids scores and
on their homework all this sort of stuff
how can people be less outcome focused
so the the one thing i like to always
point out is that
not all good results are the result of
good things
so you could do everything right and
still get a bad result
you can also do everything wrong and get
a good result
and so the results are not always the
result of bad things
or good things i should say and
results alone don't make you better
doing the right things do
and so when i look at a res results are
great
but again because of that they're not
all from the right thing
we redefine success to be the things
that are right
so for my athletes for instance i had a
i had a player that was
um in a really tough slump and
he came to me and he's just like i just
need a hit and he was really struggling
i was like i understand i totally
understand that and i said and so
how is that mentality working for you
right now
and he of course was like i get your
point
and i said okay so let's
let's look at this and let's restructure
it i said because the when the ball
leaves your bat
there is nothing you can do you may hit
you may
swing at the right pitch you may uh you
know hit it square you may do everything
right
and it just happens to go to an
outfielder and
or he makes an incredible diving catch
you know that's just that's just a
possibility
so what i care about more is redefining
success to be within our control
and so that's how i had him redefine it
so if success can't be a hit
if success can't be anything past you
hitting the ball
what would success be defined as and so
we broke it down to three things
we redefined success as number one it
was
um it was timing
so his timing at the ball so number one
timing
number two pitch selection so meaning
he's swinging at the right pitches
and number three having an external
focus he goes when i'm focused
externally on like where i want to hit
it
so it maybe he's focusing on the
batter's eye he's like i'm much
more i'm much better at actually
recognizing the pitch i need to i need
to swing at
and so that's how we redefine success we
redefined it within his control
and so for him that was the most
important piece
um because when he was able to do that
now it didn't matter what happened when
the ball left the bat
it only mattered what he did up until
then
and then what you end up finding is that
when you focus on the things that you
can control
and doing the right things those results
end up taking care of themselves
but oftentimes when we need a result
we're willing to abandon ship to get it
the problem with that is you might get
lucky every once in a while but that's
not a sustainable way to sustain success
stoicism so you should have just should
have just got marcus aurelius and he
could have been a coach
he when you left when you left to go do
it look
right gentlemen sit down i'm going to
teach you about the dichotomy of control
for a second yeah
yeah no it's fine um what about taking
things less seriously
this is something that i see a lot
people
make a big deal out of the new
presentation for work
you know they they care about it and
they're concerned this is slightly
different to the outcome
right this is taking it's losing joy in
the process
of even focusing on the process
right and i i think that a lot of times
so yes i agree that there there's
probably
it's one of those things where strengths
can become weaknesses if not managed
properly
so a strength of being really
detail-oriented really
on top of things can be a huge strength
until it's not managed properly and then
it can lead to burnout right
so i think that uh taking things less
seriously is certain a strategy
to go all right like let's look at the
big picture here
and oftentimes i think we can use
zooming in and zooming out as a good
as a good tool for that you know if if
if you're overwhelmed by the big picture
zoom into what you need to do right now
this very very moment
and then if you're so overwhelmed by
what you're in right now
zoom out to look at the big picture so
we can kind of use those different
perspectives but
my mind actually goes to something else
it goes to this idea
of formula one and in formula one
they all do something very consistently
and they pit stop
and the question is why do they pit stop
now of course there are many times that
they pits off because of mechanical
issues
but more often than not that's not the
reason why
more often than not it's a proactive
approach
for a long-term performance
to make sure that they they come in at
the right time
so that they're not only coming in if
something blows up they're not waiting
until they crash
to actually take a pit stop because that
would obviously limit their ability to
perform and so
the question becomes okay what is their
signal to pit stop you know for some of
them it's a their fuel reaches a certain
level for some of them it's tire
pressure
and then they have their refuel and they
change their tires
and then they're able to go out and
perform like they were
for a longer period of time and so my
question to a lot of people
is what is your signal to pitstop
what is your signal when the boundary of
something that is a strength
turns into a weakness what
tells you all right i need to pit stop
and refuel
maybe it's reframing maybe it's um
taking going on a walk you know maybe
it's connecting with somebody that
really
empowers you or gives you energy
whatever that is the question is
number one what do you need to like what
is your signal to pit stop
for some people it's going to feel like
overwhelm it's going to feel like
you know maybe taking yourself too
seriously and then what do you need to
do
to refuel so you can go out there and
perform your best
and so that's kind of where i go with
that because i think that for some
people it's going to be
checking in with themselves and going
like all right let's look at the big
picture like let's not take ourselves so
seriously
and that's one strategy i think that we
can use when we do pit stop
one of the common threads that yusef one
of the guys that's often on the show
mentioned
is a lot of these strategies that
multiple different people multiple
different groups are really
proselytizing about at the moment what
they boil down to
is a state change so ice bath
sauna meditation
so you've got heat changing you've got
volume of brain changing
listening to good empowering music
that's the same but on the other side
more energy
going for a walk so we're changing
visually what we're seeing we're
locomotion
so that we're moving in that kind of a
way have you seen these acupressure mats
they're like a
a little mat with a pillow and they're
kind of spiky and they hurt a little bit
but they're also satisfying a little bit
what's that doing that's a state change
it's forcing your body to feel
something else and one of my favorite
strategies actually
we have a series called life hacks and i
haven't put this in but this will be in
on a future one which is when you're
finding yourself far too much in your
own head
a lot of people that listen to this show
and perhaps yourself a very cerebral
you know we're front brain thinkers we
want to wrangle the world with our own
cognitive capacity
a lot of the time that can cause us to
ruminate and and just
get foggy up here one of the things that
i've found really helps me
is to take something that is dexterously
interesting
so a little pebble that's a unique shape
or
to run my hand across a leaf or the
steering wheel of the car if i'm sat in
the car
and focus every single bit of my
attention on the the
little perforations in the leather on
the wheel of the stitching that's on the
inside or
the way that the rock feels and the
temperature and really just try
and it pulls you out of that and again
it's another state change
and i think that the perspective that
you're talking about do we give it the
30 000 foot view and realize
this isn't too big of a deal it's going
to be okay because we're playing the
long game
or if that's too much anything oh my god
this project's so overwhelming i can't
believe i'm not going to get it done
okay what's the next action what's the
next physical action open
the email open the email and press hi
lauren or whoever it is
you know do that and um all of those
state changes i think just
give us a little bit of perspective
absolutely and are so important
for those for those moments that you're
talking about i i could not agree more
and i think the cool thing is a lot of
people will ask well which one do i do
and i can't answer that for you i try
them pick one
pick one and try it see what works best
for you i know for me one of the state
changes that works really well for me is
going on a walk
you know going on a walk and i just walk
right around my block i grab my dog
and i leave my phone at home and i just
uh the only thing i'm paying attention
to is the things around me
and kind of taking that meditative walk
what about dealing with criticism
dealing with the critics uh man this is
such a part of like my athletes lives
uh on a daily basis um even
even if within their own family not just
not just uh fans of theirs
but i think that criticism one is is a
part of
if if you're gonna do anything great you
have to know that you're going to have
critics
it's going to be a part of it and i
think one of the things that's
important and i struggled with this
myself at the very beginning of just
like
you know my own journey in my field
was before i consider the meaning
i need to consider the source
i oftentimes would attach
meanings to sources i would never ask
advice from and
there was this great analogy i heard
from uh jamie curran lee who is the
founder of a cosmetics
and she said you know everybody you
can't we can't change what people say to
us right we can't change perspectives of
other people
necessarily we can't control those
things i should say
um but we can control the volume of the
mic
in our lives
and so there are some people that you
know they have
lots of opinions but i don't they don't
carry a lot of weight in my life and so
their
their mic's pretty much been muted in my
head
and then there's people that you know
maybe it's harsh criticism but it's
valuable criticism
that i think i need to hear and i'll
turn that one up louder
and then there's people that man they
fill me up and they are the people like
that's the track i want running in my
head and that volume is
way up and so i think that there's two
sides to criticism is one
is we asking the value of it um is this
a valuable source
or is this an invaluable source
and then stripping away the emotion of
it because i think that
when emotions get involved in criticism
it can really cloud the value of it
so i know for myself you know the first
time i was told that my
presentation sucked um it was hard to
hear
you know emotionally it was hard to
detach but
i have a rule for myself is before i
respond to anything that
is kind of you know emotionally charged
like that
is i give myself 24 hours to really
consider the meaning
after i've stepped away emotionally and
created space
and so um i like to create space in
those moments
because it's often my initial reaction
that is
not the either the correct one or it's
clouded with emotion that i'm not able
to see the message
clearly so your solution to the
emotional response of the criticism
is just to give yourself a beat space
yep is to create space there um
and then i can accurately after i've
created space i'm able to actually look
at it
um you know non-judgmentally and go okay
what part of this is true
and i think the other the other part
especially for creators out there or
people that are constantly putting out
content
is um you know you're gonna have people
that just like hate your stuff
that are gonna like you know they're you
got those trolls and people that will
say things them
and that obviously hurts but i think the
more important thing is to find the
consistency
is that if there are consistent things
that people are saying there may be some
truth to that
so i try to look at like what my
audience says to me and like
okay so maybe i wasn't as clear in this
point and trying not to take it like an
emotional like hit but more because
sometimes the tone doesn't come across
in text
but trying to find the consistencies
there but i would say that there's
you know like i said there's a couple
things which is one is
rating the value and then two if there
is value and you're feeling emotionally
charged is to create some space
my phrases matt fraser tweeted something
a couple of
months ago where he said don't take
criticism from someone you wouldn't take
advice from
yep and nicole arbour
who is a magnet for hatred online
because of what she puts out
she mentioned something like i've almost
never been criticized by someone who's
better than me at what i do
and those are nice defensive mechanisms
but i think that we need something a
little bit more nuanced like you've said
there
because even with all of those things in
mind just being cast offish and
disregarding what people say
the emotion's still going to be they're
still going to be triggered by the
things
that occur so you need something more
scalable and i think giving yourself
time
thinking about okay where's this coming
from what maybe why is it triggering
something in me
because a lot of the things that are
nice about other people are things that
we fear that we may manifest in
ourselves
we hate the lazy person at work because
deep down we're worried that we might be
lazy
that's why it really triggers us because
we think [ __ ] that could be me
maybe that is me and that's one of the
things that we need to be careful of
i had a a couple of episodes recently as
the channel's grown
i'm starting to reach what i call the
real internet so you've got
the normal internet right which is your
audience then you have the real internet
you know the ones that are
slinging feces at each other and
supposed to post apocalyptic wasteland
out there people are mad maxing all over
the place
and um those people
are the ones that are really interesting
to do
exposure therapy on for this sort of
stuff had an episode
that went out this week that was talking
about sexual conflict between
men and women and we had i had comments
that both said it was far too
pro-feminism
and that it was obviously uh completely
immersed in liberal bias
and then another bunch of comments that
said well this is com
absolute patriarchal ridiculousness i'm
thinking right okay so
people on both sides of the aisle are
unable to see the thing that the other
one's doing
um and with that in mind you think
there are people that this is the same
piece of content they haven't watched
two different things
they've watched the same thing and come
up with completely opposing criticisms
about them
so okay am i supposed to believe one of
them both of them neither of them
well probably neither of them because
they kind of cancel each other out
and that's why is it don miguel ruiz and
his four agreements thing
that's one of the reasons that he says
to never take criticism personally
because that person at that time in that
place said
that thing it doesn't mean that it's
right it doesn't even mean that it's
what they meant
they just made some mouth noises or
thumb shapes and
now you're taking it like gospel wisdom
descended from the heavens ready to
inform you about something that you know
how to do
and and this person doesn't what about
yeah what about when someone is
struggling
over a longer term you've used the word
slump a couple of times
if someone's got into this negative
spiral how
can they we'd call it the yips
in cricket where the bowlers running up
to bowl and he just can't hit his length
he's spraying it all over the place he's
just
in his own head are there some
strategies that people can do for
a more protracted macro longer term
period of struggling with
getting themselves into the performance
yeah so one of the things that
um i noticed in those moments that
worked really really well is just
especially going back to the foundation
um the foundation that kind of
built the home because if you think
about by the time somebody's struggling
to that degree
especially at a certain level the house
is pretty much built
and you know we've got we're now just
like designing the inside
right and so when we're when we're
noticing
kind of this shaky foundation that's
where i like to go back to is
okay let's go back to that foundation
the thing that is holding everything
together
and so we go back to the basics and the
fundamentals of what made you great in
the first place
because a lot of times like i said like
i was telling you is that the longer
when we're focused on the gap between
where we are and where we want to be
nothing but perfection will do
because any anything less than
perfection means that gap is widening
it's getting bigger and bigger and
bigger
and what do you think that happens
anxiety stress
frustration just continues to also grow
in size
with with this and so one of the things
like i said i like to go back to is the
fundamentals and focusing
on progress from the fundamental level
so one of the things that actually the
military does is
when they're working on cleaning their
guns they actually have
this strategy where they start off like
ridiculously like comically slow
when they're put piecing their their gun
back together so this is for instance if
they're
in a situation where somebody's in the
middle of cleaning it and then
they need to use it and so how do you
get it back as quickly as possible
and so they do it like meticulously slow
like like
like okay now i gotta put this part here
and i've gotta
like as slow as possible it's like
hilarious and then
the reason why they do that is they
train it at the slowest level
and they start with accuracy then they
add speed
and so their main goal is accuracy
at every level of speed and so they
start at the slowest
speed and then they slowly go upward
from there
and so that's one of the things that's
one strategy and one of the things that
we can do
is by taking the fundamentals and
focusing
so much on our accuracy and then adding
the speed of the game
as we go and every time we kind of
master that level of speed
then we can add a little bit more and
every time we
master a level it's a confidence builder
so when we can prove to ourselves that
we can do that and so anyway it's
it's pretty comical at the very
beginning of it but uh but that's one of
the one of the tools that we can use one
of the tools that we
have used and strategies we've pulled
from the military
who are some of the toughest people that
you've studied
this is her really you know why i think
some of the toughest people
are they're the ones that
number one number one they just don't
say yes to anything
which is totally to me it's a challenge
um i had this athlete
for instance he came in um i should say
this they're the toughest
and most enjoyable long term and i'll
tell you why
i had this athlete come in and i had
this kind of you know form that he
filled out and every player fills it out
and then it's kind of like our way to
introduce ourselves
you know to meet them and then uh kind
of get a little bit of a background on
them
i he stops me just before i start going
into this intake form
and he goes um i just have to tell you i
filled that out um it's courtesy
it's like oh okay all right so you you
just did this
like are any of these true i'm here and
you guys i don't know and i asked him
do you want to go over this and he's
like no
so right there i literally shredded it i
tore it in half and i threw it away
and i said well these next 30 minutes
are yours what do you want me to know
about you
or what do you want to talk about what
can i help you with and he started
asking me questions
and so it was like the role was reversed
and i was like all right let's let's
chat
but what he was doing was
he is not a yes man which is fine we
don't want all yes people
but he wanted to make sure that what he
was implementing
worked and he wanted to know more about
it
and so he he had had really bad
experiences with mental conditioning
somewhere else and so to no fault of his
own he was pretty skeptical
so anyway i think you know long term
what ended up happening was instead of
forcing him on these topics
i just would ask him like hey do you
even do you want to talk about this and
he'd say no in a bit great what do you
want to talk about sometimes we ended up
talking about like
the football game that just happened or
you know it's whatever else it was
and we developed this level of trust
to the point where he actually it's a
funny he hates jocko
which i can't believe because i love
jocko but he can't stand his content for
whatever reason
and it got to the point where he trusted
me enough where he asked me to send him
a jocko book he goes all right i want to
see what this is all about
and sent him the book and he fell in
love with him so he's now
a joker fan yes but some of the toughest
individuals the ones that push back at
the beginning
to me it all matter like relationship is
the first thing that matters
is that a lot of times it's not because
they just
outright hate this stuff but because the
relationship to it isn't there
and so some of the toughest people i've
worked with have also been the most
enjoyable because
they also force you to really know your
[ __ ]
it's not just about like oh i'm the
expert and here i know about mental
performance
but they question everything and by
questioning things
it actually forces you to understand
your argument even further
and so for me i think the toughest
athletes to work with are the
the best or like end up being some of
the best clients
because they make me a better
practitioner in the process at the same
time
and i think that it creates uh you know
new solutions
in that way that maybe otherwise we may
have not have come up with or thought of
what would you ask jocko if you had the
opportunity
i think i'd want to ask him this
question because it's one of my favorite
questions to ask
if you were in a leadership role
and you do ever you did everything you
knew to do
and you still failed why would that be
what would be the reason for failure
and the reason why i asked that is
because
i would love to hear how he works
through
like that question in terms of what
would be
his the thing that he falls on what
would be the thing that he struggles at
what would be the thing that
is maybe his vice and how would he work
through
having to face that because i think he
is one of
an incredible model of leadership and i
would want to know
what is that area that even even you
think could be a struggle or that you're
continuing to develop
that's a good question if i get him on
i'm going to steal that one
beautiful love it lauren johnson ladies
and gentlemen thank you very much for
coming on
people want to check out more of your
stuff where should they go
um they can go to my website at
laurenjohnsonco.com i have a
newsletter you can subscribe to and all
my social media handles are on there
perfect catch you next time all right
thank you
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy indeed
peace